opposers I got a level with you I hate
to end on a downer yr clappers choice
vitamin supplements are medically
classified as uppers still by bad news
it's about the memo you know the one for
pages black ink rectangular classified
waived around for the past few weeks by
House Republicans as proof that the FBI
and Justice Department abused their
authority in getting a surveillance
warrant for Trump advisor Carter page or
to put that more simply that Trump is
innocent molars a witch hunt end of
story hashtag mega hashtag stand for the
anthem now that it's finally out the
lefty media is calling it a dud but so
what you can't trust a word that spelled
the same front and back words if you
think you can I have one word freedom
Wow and race car two words the real bad
news is that some Republicans are
joining in these backstabbers are saying
this memo doesn't discredit the mulher
investigation so you don't agree with
President Trump and he says this
vindicates them in the entire rush
investigation I don't do you agree that
it that it vindicates from I think this
is a separate issue this memo has
frankly nothing at all to do with
Special Counsel the memo has no impact
on the Russia probe
no no not to me it doesn't
No Oh dare you Gaudi you're the House
Republican who holds the record for
saying Benghazi 4,000 times on TV now
you just throw Trump under the bus just
because you're retiring still I guess
that's it the memo failed
Mulder's probe will continue and it's
only a matter of time until he closes it
will be right now close close close
close close good good good are the
Liberals gone I'll check huh
sure wish someone would rake the best
flavors of Lacroix okay good they're
gone
because this is just between us opposers
the memo wasn't a failure it was a huge
success
who cares what trey Gowdy says he's too
focused on being the model for the Ocean
Spray wave so yeah the memo didn't prove
what it claimed to prove and completely
lacks substance the American people
don't care about substance if they did
they wouldn't have made Ari the bachelor
and so what if this memo doesn't do
anything to discredit them all our
investigation in a court of law that's
fine they're only two courts that matter
food and public opinion and this memo is
dominating in the court of public
opinion after Trump released the memo
Axios reported that less than 40% of
Republicans approve of the FBI more
actually disapprove of the FBI it's
getting to the point now where
Republicans are watching Silence of the
Lambs and rooting for Buffalo Bill
guess what you know who Republicans do
like the President Trump tweeted that
this memo totally vindicates him that's
all we need to hear what do you think
people are more likely to read an
endlessly long four page memo or Trump's
snappy tweet about that four page memo
you think I read those two es Keyes
notes from the underground in high
school oh I just read Trump's tweet
about it Ryan Mole Man suffers from
ennui sad puts thing in a way that I can
finally understand because it's just
what I want to hear no one is going to
remember the contents of this memo you
know what they are gonna remember em you
D when you are the president when you
have an ally in the chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee you get to
muddy the waters the waters are so muddy
right now muddying the waters muddy the
water as all of this kind of muddied the
waters yes
yes that's right this memo has muddied
the waters and muddy water is the best
water exfoliates it relaxes makes you
calm down and believe the things you
already believe what I believe is that
Trump's innocent and the FBI is a secret
society of and Tifa thugs and This
American Life listeners trying to take
him down
here's great news it's not just this
memo newness plans on releasing even
more memos as many as five and the
Democrats are trying to release their
own memo to fight our memo have I said
memo enough times for you to forget that
Donald Trump is suspected of collusion
good that's the whole point but why stop
at memos there's all sorts of documents
that might vindicate Trump that we just
haven't seen yet brochures pamphlets
leaflets napkins
I bet Devon noonas has a post-it note
somewhere that we could milk for weeks
look what does that say buy milk or
Robert Muller is Hillary Clinton on
stilts we'll never know until we release
the post-its
we're in for a fun few weeks and then
we'll move on to the next one
[Music]